something remarkable is happening here
at the river saw in the English Midlands
against all the odds one of the
Premiership smallest clubs is only a few
points away from capturing the title my
club leicester city
I'm making the journey back to the
Midlands where my brother lives and
where I spent my childhood I want to
find out more about how leicester city
football club a team of unknowns is
brushing aside the mega rich elite fans
all over the world have been captivated
by the foxes but does anyone know what
the secrets of this extraordinary season
is
I met my brother at his local sports
club on the outskirts of the city so I'm
why is it white it is well I can't I
mean about I asked laser people i think
it's teamwork it's consistency of team
selection and i just think they were on
a roll because i went to lots of games
last year and they were even when they
were losing they were playing well they
get some losing one nil the biggest
Lester fan I know is my nephew Tom now
studying in Newcastle's that one is I
think that's where he went to what is
his first games because we got his face
painted with elasticity I think I'm so
happy yeah do you ever wish game he was
no kind of that weekend away owns a home
game it was nil no I can't remember who
they played that but he loved it he had
a hot dog where's that Lynn that he's on
holiday that's made him clowning about
but he's got his full City awake it on
there when Lester beat man city 3 one
away in February even the biggest after
started taking them seriously Lester a
team costing only 20 million tore apart
the champions who cost 10 times there no
wonder people are getting carried away
I got warned by policeman's calm down
there I was like calm doubt you mean
calm down do you know what this actually
means to it
Lester mania is growing week by week
around England but if the Foxes do win
the title it will mean most but diehard
fans it's the never-say-die attitude is
the the little club against the big boys
and we are still a little club although
we are top of the league and we have got
a great chance of winning the league we
are still that little Club in the
Midlands in the centre of England you
know I just think it just gives hope to
every club doesn't it we've always been
the underdog summit way and so I think
it's good that we've kind of proved
everyone wrong it doesn't take millions
of pounds worth of players just to prove
that we can win Premier League if we win
the league this year it's just [ __ ]
there's still the if there's still the
earth but hopefully um yeah we're there
we're going to be a global club now
listen we've all been football fans who
always got something to moan about
Lester's about the only Club in the
world where there's nothing to moan
about everything is going one hundred
percent right now right this minute what
can we possibly want this different but
things weren't always that Rosie back in
2002 the club went into administration
led by former player Gary Lineker a
consortium of fans and businessmen safe
the club from bankruptcy Lester had
built a new stadium hoping to cash in on
a new TV deal but they were left with
huge debts and the club has been
recovering ever since I met up with Ian
Basin chairman of the Foxes trust he was
one of the fans belonging to the group
the safer club back in 2002 less this
title of it actually began as a fight
for sheer survival
yeah it is fantastic and it's doubly so
because have helping to say the club I
mean obviously if we hadn't done that
back in two thousand to the club would
have folded been reformed gone into
non-league tier whatever I've been
making its way back up hopefully it
certainly wouldn't been where we are now
and certainly the current owners
wouldn't have been attracted to buy the
club in the first place foreign owners
of English clubs are often quite
unpopular here to Leicester of the
exception the owners from Thailand have
proved a perfect match for the club this
is also providing a great blend of new
money an old football in culture I think
in comparison to our littles we're
really lucky with the owners we've got
in terms of how they they recognize the
heritage of the club and that they're
keen for that to represent it and the
like see former players here and they
will always say I mean King pads
branding look Lee's blue and in fact I
think that was the key thing for them
taking over was the fact that they
wanted a side the played in blue but
they won't change that they understand
they recognized heritage is important in
any football club to see just how far
less have come I take a walk and meet
Henry Doyle a local solicitor who
initially represented the trust this is
all that's left of filbert street the
team's old home grounds in the 1970s
Henry told me about the difference
between now and then I think you're in
the services
we've got a fantastic stadium here as of
many other clubs so one except that
there is something to pay for that and I
think actually looking at my own
position is that as a season ticket
holder I look at the price and I'm not
too unhappy but I do know that if I want
to get a ticket for a friend or remember
my family for a one-off that is it very
expensive you know he used to be the
working man's game and you would say
with all the corporate hospitality
element of now football particularly
large cloves that that doesn't necessary
to be the case and and you know
particularly the ones we were
particularly worried about in fact the
trust movement worries about is people
are 18 to 21 year olds these days
because they they finish they obviously
get discounted rates when the children
suddenly though then regarded as adults
and the pricing level leaps massively so
you potentially could see those people
lose out from being in the ground and
maybe three years later when they're not
going to go they may never return
because they used to them watching in
the pub
match day 35 for the first time Lester's
coaches acknowledge that the Foxes could
take the typhoon I can't remember a time
when I wanted a team to win this much a
victory would be a huge step towards
making the fairy tale reality and there
goes my journalistic objectivity
the king power stadium witnessed an
emphatic four-nil victory
today they came out they did the usual
food so not know fear they wanted to win
they needed to win and we did it Cornell
fantastic what I've just seen Rhonda
just fold over letters win for now just
excited asset now that's done all over
finished we're going to leap down that's
it we've won the new after the nearest
rivals Tottenham drew over the weekend
Lester only need one more win who can
doubt it now this is the year of the Fox
you